uh did this feel different than the
other wins this season because of
everything that had happened yeah you
know it's been a minute so yeah it does
feel good kind of felt like a playoff
game to me but uh you know we of course
we have to feel good about it so we love
that feeling we want to repeat it so
yeah we we're going to keep working our
ass off you mentioned it feeling like a
playoff game your reaction there at the
end putting the two arms up just did it
feel like it was just just a month and a
half worth of release just in that
moment yes you know
it's not like I forgot about that
feeling but you
know and of course I never want to lose
again but it's going to happen and but
and we got to enjoy those moments you
know cuz this is what I'm I'm addicted
to win and this is what I love and you
know it's it's what I live for so I have
to I have to show it you
know